انتصار ليفربول المؤكد على
ترسانة أرسنال في اليوم الثالث من
الموسم الجديد للدوري الإنجليزي الممتاز
هو دليل آخر على أن الأبطال
ليسوا مصممين فقط على الاحتفاظ بلقبهم
ولكن لديهم جميع الأدوات للقيام بذلك ، لذا
سيطروا على الاستحواذ
وكان لديهم المزيد من التسديدات على المرمى.  حقيقة
أن أرسنال كان لديه العديد
من الفرص الواضحة
تقريبًا ترجع إلى
أسلوب ليفربول الهجومي العدواني
مثل أي نقاط ضعف في الدفاع تحدث إلى
فريق ريتشارد سعي مؤخرًا يعتقد
اللاعب السابق أسطورة ليفربول جيمي كاراغر
أن المزيد من النجاح
قاب قوسين أو أدنى.
هذه اللحظة ،
بطل أفضل فريق في الدوري ،
لا أرى أن هذا يتغير هذا الموسم
، وقد يستمر عهد يورغن كلوب هذا لفترة طويلة
وهذا الفريق
عندما فاز بدوري الأبطال
لم يخسروا الدوري إلا
بنقطة كانت بضع سنوات.  قبل ذلك
، أثبت هذا الفريق أنه يمكنني القيام بذلك من
قبل ولن أتفاجأ إذا كان
بإمكانهم فعل ذلك مرة أخرى ، فهناك ثلاثة أو أربعة
فرق  أفضل الفرق في
أوروبا وليفربول هي واحدة منهم
وأحيانًا تحتاج إلى نفض العملة المعدنية وما
إذا كانت تسقط في طريقك أم لا ،
لكن ليفربول يمكنه بالتأكيد الفوز
بالدوري الممتاز ولا شك في أن
دوري الأبطال في نفس الموسم
بتدبير أول
إنجليزي لليفربول  إن النجاح في لقب البطولة لمدة
ثلاثة
عقود في السنة بعد توجيه النادي إلى
مدربه السادس في دوري أبطال أوروبا يورغن كلوب
يضمن بالفعل مكانة البطل
ويقول كاراغر إن
شعبية المدرب لا تتعلق فقط بكرة القدم ،
بل كان لديه هذه العلاقة في كل نادٍ
كان عليه قبل ذلك.  ليس
فقط لليفربول الذي كان محبوبًا ،
فهناك الأندية التي كان قد نشأ من قبل ، ولهذا السبب
أحضره ليفربول إلى هنا
وأصبح على اتصال
الآن بالمدينة وسكانها حيث
يشعر أنه يشبهه لاعبًا
ألمانيًا ، فهل نقول هذا
هذا هو لقبه الآن
في المدينة لقد فكر
هكذا وأعتقد أننا نمر بيوم حزين عندما
يغادر ليف.  حقق إيربول الآن ثلاثة انتصارات
من ثلاث مباريات بالدوري الممتاز
، وقد تحسن مع كل مباراة ،
المباريات القادمة ضد المنافسين المحليين إيفرتون ومانشستر
سيتي ، النادي
الذي نجحوا فيه
كأبطال سيعطينا فكرة أفضل إذا كانت هذه
بالفعل بداية
سلالة أخرى في الأنفيلد